hey there fellow townscapers and welcome
back to the channel if this is your
first time here welcome welcome welcome
and thank you so much for stopping by it
is always appreciated when you guys stop
by to see what i'm doing
so today's video is about a new
up-and-coming city builder game but
before we talk about it i want to talk
about the paint over contest i want to
congratulate the first two paint over
contest winners my drill keys and blue
mizel they did amazing work and you can
see their entries in the gallery on the
website we also have a new entry from
the dank boy and i really really like
their work as you can see it's a
watercolor paint over and i think it was
executed very well i love watercolor so
i think it was a very beautiful job you
can view their entry on the gallery also
if you want to win a free copy of
townscaper for you or a friend you can
enter by clicking the link in the
description the video will tell you
everything that you need to know about
entering so you'll know how to access
the entry form and how to submit your
photos
so now that we've gotten that out the
way let's get into what we're all here
for i broke my own rule
if you look on my about page you will
see that this channel is solely
dedicated to townscaper almost like a
shrine if you will but today i want to
talk about castrudo i was contacted by
daniel wolfson the creator of costrudo
and i was asked to test the program and
i gladly accepted i'm obsessed with city
building games so it was a no-brainer
for me so let's just get right into it
and let's talk about it costrudo is
about building your dream italian villa
placing block to block in the middle of
nowhere in the ocean you can choose your
style from more than five different
variations and there is no particular
essence of the game you just need to
keep calm and build to the relaxing
wildfire music i like castrudo because
it's very chill i like the texture of
the structures and as you can see it
really looks like an italian villa it
has the shutters on your windows and the
drainage pipes on the side to really
give you that realistic feel the music
is beautiful as a fan of lo-fi i really
enjoy the soundtrack there are eight
lo-fi tracks so you have a nice set of
music to build to there's also an active
daylight cycle and you can change the
time of day also by using this dial here
so you can literally build from dusk
until dawn which i just love i think
that's my favorite part and i also think
that is a very nice touch of realism as
well the water also looks great and i
love watching it move as the sun rises
and sets on my builds cosrudo is
currently in beta so there are limits to
the game such as build height and grid
size but there are features that will be
added later
after testing i spoke with daniel and i
asked him some questions about the
development of castruto and you know
just what to expect in the near future
so daniel has informed me that there are
plans to add more settings modding
capabilities more specifically the steam
workshop could be involved and there are
also plans for a campaign random map
generation and much more some things
that i would personally like to see
would be keyboard controls and the
ability to add custom music almost like
how you use self radio on grand theft
auto you know how you would take your
music files and you put them into a
folder and the game will pull those
files from the folder and they will play
them for you i honestly think that would
be nice i also think it would be nice to
have a longer daylight cycle the
daylight cycle is about two minutes long
which isn't bad however more daylight is
good i think maybe it could be a setting
where you could adjust the time to your
preference and i think that would be
very cool so if you want it to be longer
if you want your day to be 10 minutes
long you could do so if you wanted to be
less than two minutes you could do that
as well i'm gonna show you guys some
gameplay you know just so you can get an
idea of what castrudo is like if you
enjoy this video and you want to try out
costrudo it will be available to the
public on the 16th of february and
that's this coming wednesday so you can
mark your calendar or you can make it
easier on yourself and you can add it to
your wish list the link is in the
description below so you can just go in
the description you can click on that
link and the link will take you to steam
and if you're logged in you can just add
it to that wishlist well that is all i
have for today but i will leave you all
with the gameplay so you can see
castrito for yourself i hope you all
enjoy it remember that all the important
links are in the description below i
want to thank you guys so much for
stopping by i can't stress that enough i
really really appreciate all the love
and support if you enjoyed this content
please like the video and share it with
people that you know would enjoy it as
well also please subscribe as it does
help me out a lot i'm almost at 2 000
subscribers and i can't do it without
you guys and i would really really
really really appreciate it so please if
you can subscribe to the channel i would
be so grateful so with that being said
i'll let you all go and i will see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you